[Música]
sí
siempre me ha interesado saber por qué
tenemos tanta tendencia a mantenernos
digamos inactivos o sea porque nos gusta
tanto la inactividad la pasividad porque
el carácter de una persona permanece a
lo largo de los años es algo bastante
interesante que es lo que hace que una
sociedad se estabilice y se construya
sobre los miembros de la misma
entonces reflexionando sobre todo esto
sobre el caos el prestigio y el
equilibrio social lo difícil es poder
encontrar alguna relación entre estas
tres palabras no hay ahí en la
fotografía un dibujo que me está
hablando que me dice que ha aterrizado
en la tierra con su artefacto para estar
en busca de vida inteligente
lo de vida inteligente primero habría
que definir lo que sería la inteligencia
la inteligencia es una capacidad para
poder elegir aquellas cosas que son las
más apropiadas pero cómo podemos saber
cuáles son las cosas más apropiadas qué
es lo que más nos interesa una manera de
saberlo naturalmente tiene que pasar por
entender el ambiente en el que estamos
en el universo en el que vivimos
vivimos en un mundo realmente complejo
nosotros como seres humanos formamos
parte de ese mundo pero ese mundo es
también nosotros los seres humanos somos
seres biológicos somos seres vivos y en
qué consiste ser un ser vivo en mi libro
de biología decía que un ser vivo era
aquel que era capaz de relacionarse de
alimentarse y con un poco de suerte de
reproducirse y parece ser que los seres
vivos nos incluyen a nosotros como
miembros además de eso resulta que somos
seres químicos cualquiera de nosotros
somos una pequeña central térmica que a
partir de los alimentos que ingerimos
somos capaces de generar una corriente
estable de unos 100 vatios es muy fácil
hacer los cálculos por ese motivo cuando
aquí hay 100 personas es el aire
acondicionado tiene que evacuar 10
kilovatios el equivalente a 10 estufas
de un kilovatio simplemente para
mantener la temperatura
aparte de eso formamos parte del mundo
químico somos seres químicos perdón
físicos
como sabemos que somos seres físicos
sufrimos las mismas fuerzas que sufren
todas las demás partes de la materia que
conocemos no conozco todavía a ningún
científico que cuando tropieza y se cae
se queda estampado contra el techo
normalmente que hay al suelo es una
demostración muy elemental pero que
indica que tenemos características
físicas y cada una de esas capas influye
en nuestro comportamiento influye
nuestro comportamiento el ser seres
humanos en el ser seres vivos el ser
unos seres que tienen unas reacciones
químicas y también el ser seres físicos
de la misma manera que hemos ido digamos
de dentro a fuera ahora vamos a intentar
hacer el camino contrario una especie de
introspección
cómo es el mundo físico el mundo físico
la palabra que desde mi punto de vista
lo define es es un caos el mundo físico
es un caos y muchos grandes científicos
se han dedicado lo mejor de su
experiencia y de sus estudios a poder
conocer de qué está hecha la materia o
cómo se comporta
hay un científico genial que es newton
que nos legó el conocimiento sobre la
inercia desde mi punto de vista es la
aportación más importante de newton a la
tienda el explicar que la materia no
quiere acelerarse no quiere cambiar su
estado de equilibrio
vinieron luego otros como por ejemplo
plank que nos explicó que esa energía
que tenemos que darle a la materia para
moverse para acelerar se transmite en en
paquetes no es una función continua
heisenberg no se introdujo el concepto
de incertidumbre es materialmente
imposible conocer con exactitud la
posición y la energía de una simple
partícula cuanto más de un cuerpo
verdaderamente complejo como el nuestro
por si faltaba algo schrödinger nos
explicó que las partículas materiales
tenían también características de onda
es un mundo realmente difícil de
entender tan difícil de entender que
otros científicos como von
e intentaron explicar la aleatoriedad el
comportamiento aleatorio que parece
arbitrario
en base a variables ocultas variables
que además va a ser realmente muy
difícil que podamos investigar por qué
ocurren en distancias realmente
ridículas
y ya por si acaso faltaba penrose
explicando cómo se puede dividir digamos
en el conocimiento en tres grandes
grupos por un lado estaría nuestro
nuestro conocimiento a base de fórmulas
y a bases de algoritmos sería un mundo
platónico que intenta explicar un
universo físico y por otro parte nuestra
conciencia que es la que elabora esos
algoritmos y esas fórmulas forma parte
del mundo físico entonces se establece
una especie de rueda el pensamiento
realmente es un una materia que es
incompatible no no hay manera de
resumirlo en forma de ecuaciones
bien y qué opinan los químicos ya hemos
pasado la la página ahora estamos en el
mundo químico a mí el trabajo que más me
impresiona en el mundo químico es el de
el satélite que habla sobre el
equilibrio bien y qué es el equilibrio
antes habíamos hablado del equilibrio en
digamos en la newton cuando nos hablaba
de que la materia quiere estar en
equilibrio pero que ese equilibrio en
química si añadimos en un vaso de
precipitados un par de sustancias ahí ve
que son reactivas pues reaccionarán y
darán como resultado otras sustancias
mediante una reacción que es la que
ponemos como entre paréntesis
inmediatamente se forman los productos
ce y de ellos reaccionan a su vez para
volver a producir los reactivos que les
han dado origen esto es algo que ocurre
naturalmente y ocurre en continuo ocurre
de tal manera que llega un momento en el
que ambas velocidades de reacción se
equilibran y entonces se produce el
estado de equilibrio el estado de
equilibrio en química no es un estado
estático es un estado completamente
dinámico y tiene unas propiedades
espectaculares porque ocurre que el
producto de las concentraciones de las
sustancias que formaban parte de la
reacción es una constante
esa constante significa lo siguiente si
yo intento modificar la concentración de
algunas de las sustancias participantes
en la reacción
el sistema vuelve a reaccionar por
ejemplo si quito el producto de
que había aparecido aquí como resultado
de la reacción porque es un gas o más
bien volverán a reaccionar para volver a
producir c + d es decir volverán a
intentar producir lo que ha faltado lo
que se ha ido
eso significa se conoce como el
principio del y seattle y que yo lo
simplificó de una manera muy elemental
diciendo que un sistema en equilibrio se
adapta a los cambios el sistema está
reaccionando se defiende de lo que está
ocurriendo en su exterior es estable no
quiere moverse es exactamente igual de
inerte que la materia que no quiere
acelerar o sea que en química tenemos un
principio muy semejante al al físico que
pasa con los seres vivos seguimos
nuestra introspección y aquí hemos
dibujado un ser vivo en su entorno este
ser vivo está recibiendo alimentos y
produce desechos y además tiene otras
interacciones que son estímulos que
recibe del exterior y a su vez produce
señales llega un momento en el que se
estabiliza porque en su interior hay un
equilibrio es un equilibrio básicamente
químico
la que está puesta a propósito es
representa el anabolismo y la cee
representa el catabolismo en conjunto es
el metabolismo es decir que este ser
vivo que ha salido incluso yo diría
bastante apetitoso parece una croqueta
verdad tiene un aspecto así como
comestible se comporta también como se
comportaba en el vaso de precipitados de
la reacción química de tal forma que si
hay algo que intenta cambiar su estado
una amenaza reacciona
de qué manera reacciona normalmente
reacciona de una de estas dos maneras o
escondiéndose se apartándose de la
amenaza o contra atacando y cuando
consigue tener éxito entonces recibe una
sensación de agrado que podemos
simplificar con la palabra placer recibe
un placer un agrado el placer entonces
es una medida de la estabilidad que
consigue este ser vivo con su reacción a
una agresión del medio
diríamos que esto sería la base de una
moral individual que afecta a todos los
seres vivos y está moral individual es
una moral egoísta pretende salvarse a sí
mismo
qué pasa ahora con los seres humanos los
seres humanos pertenecen a varios grupos
a múltiples grupos y también establecen
una serie de relaciones con el grupo la
más elemental es el ser humano
proporciona un trabajo al grupo fruto de
su esfuerzo y recibe un salario
también recibe una educación algo muy
importante y transmite algo que yo llamo
reproducción cultural que es todos sus
conocimientos los transmite a la
siguiente generación ya podéis imaginar
que aquí se establecerá otro equilibrio
pero vamos a esperar un momento este
equilibrio no será en el interior del
ser humano será del ser humano con el
grupo es un equilibrio que trasciende el
ser humano
cuando este ser humano tiene una acción
realmente notable algo que es que
definimos como altruismo incluso
poniendo en peligro su vida recibe un
gran premio del grupo que se llama
prestigio
el prestigio es por lo tanto una medida
de la estabilidad que consigue el grupo
con la acción de este ser humano por lo
tanto vamos hemos reproducido algo
semejante a lo que ocurría con la moral
individual pero aquí la moral de grupo
es una moral altruista el grupo se va
reforzando cada vez que alguien del
mismo está realizando algo en favor del
del grupo y así él se traban en
relaciones más intensas y más estables
fijaros una cosa muy curiosa tanto el
prestigio o reconocimiento o gloria
que puede ser cualquiera de estos
sinónimos como el placer en el
comportamiento individual son medidas al
igual que ocurre con las medidas y en la
escala
subatómica resulta que las medidas
pueden modificar el experimento de hecho
lo que ocurre es que tanto el placer
como prestigio
se convierten en verdaderos estímulos o
causas de la acción ya no son las
medidas sino que las personas vamos
detrás de conseguir una situación más
placentera y de conseguir un mayor
reconocimiento es tan poderoso el
prestigio que yo he estado próximo a
conseguir el premio nobel esto lo sabe
muy poca gente pero lo sabe mi profesor
de química orgánica que así me lo dijo
cuando yo me examiné estando haciendo el
servicio militar y no había podido
acudir a las clases hice un examen y él
tenía ganas de conocerme me dijo hombre
teodoro a usted quería yo conocerle
y sabe que usted tendría que ganar el
premio nobel ya lo dijo el condicional
cuidado si fuera verdad lo que puso en
el examen vale de acuerdo fue totalmente
no sea una ilusión momentánea pero a mí
la verdad es que me animó bastante a
continuar esa es un ejemplo un poco más
prosaicos que lo que nos contaba steve
jobs pero va en el mismo sentido en el
sentido de obtener un reconocimiento
les recomiendo que lean un libro de
wisner martín wisner el poder de las
historias
se puede encontrar en cualquier librería
y es un profesor de literatura explica
cómo 'alejandro magno' antes de
conquistar así antes de vencer a darío
el rey persa que era el tercer era el
enemigo de toda la vida de los griegos
fue a troya a rendir homenaje a los
héroes troyanos a perdón a los seres
griegos que asediaron y vencieron a la
ciudad de troya
el libro que le orientó a hacer esto era
la ilíada el poema de la iliada el libro
se lo regaló a aristóteles que era su
maestro y junto con una daga y una caja
que le arrebató a darío eran los tres
objetos la ilíada la caja y la daga los
tres objetos que él siempre llevaba
consigo en sus hazañas
entonces después de todo lo que les he
comentado y de las interacciones tan
importantes que existen tanto a nivel
individual como a nivel estrictamente
humano a ver si va a ser verdad que un
poema vale más que mil ecuaciones para
intentar averiguar cómo se comporta el
ser humano y eso es todo
[Aplausos]